change the world
so
it's my turn
um i think there's we've heard a lot of
great talks today but i think no day at
the gsb would be complete without a talk
about entrepreneurship so here i am and
here we all are at stanford in the heart
of silicon valley and if you think and
if you've been thinking that more and
more startups seem to be starting up
every day
you're right
according to kyle schrum who's the head
of the kaufman foundation
we now live in the most entrepreneurial
time in history
just think about that for a second
and i am part of the most
entrepreneurial generation
so
i want to start by sharing a story
another case study from this most
entrepreneurial generation of line
it's the story of 24 year old timmy an
entrepreneur i met this summer when i
was running a program to help him start
his business
now
timmy did everything right he
found a real customer need he devised an
innovative distribution method for his
product and it just went gangbusters he
sold out the very first day he launched
he sold out in two hours and doubled his
money and now he's on the track to
expanding his business and creating jobs
so that's pretty much a textbook case of
the successful young entrepreneur story
right
and it is
but here's the thing it didn't happen
here in palo alto
but here
in lagos nigeria
now lagos is one of the world's fastest
growing mega cities
seventy percent of the population lives
in slums and sixty percent of the
economic activity is in the informal
sector
timmy's full name is timalehan akinpelu
he grew up in a polygamous family where
the three wives of his father and all
their children crowded into one small
room
his product was not some sort of
ecommerce luxury thing but rather hand
sanitizer affordably and attractively
distributed in recycled water bottles
and his customers
were these folks trash pickers
homeless migrants who crowd the
sprawling slums of this mega city
rooting through trash with their bare
hands under the sun every day
so
timmy's probably not the typical
entrepreneur right he's not he's not the
typical person we think of when we think
of the successful young
business person starting some sort of
world-changing venture
but i argue that we should think more
about timmy and invest in folks like him
so
the reason why is that 15 only 15 of my
entrepreneurial generation are in rooms
like this one on campuses like this one
the other
85 percent
um
are in developing countries
they are youth crowded into the slums of
these desperate mega cities
stuck in informal sector work that's
often precarious and exploitative
and for them the only mainstream stories
they hear about youth making it
are just that
fantasies stories like this one slumdog
millionaire this movie about a street
youth who makes it big and wins the
grand prize
in a game show that's kind of like who
wants to be a millionaire millionaire so
you know i'm all for fortune and fate
and game shows but the truth is these
aren't real solutions for the majority
of the 85 percent
and this majority is increasingly poor
disenfranchised and desperate
i think we need to find a better way to
put slum youth on the track to becoming
slum millionaires
and i think the way to do this is by
tapping our entrepreneurial generation
that's what i've been doing for the last
three years in the slums of lagos
working with youth like timmy to start
businesses
and what i want to talk about with you
today is why the 85 percent matters
what how how we go about tapping their
incredible world-changing potential
and what we can all do what help i need
from you to make this happen
so let's start with the why
it's about youth
so it turns out that not only am i part
of the most entrepreneurial generation
but also the most populous and the most
precarious
according to the world bank we're the
largest youth cohort in human history
and we are leading the largest mass
migration in human history from the the
world's rural areas to urban centers
and employers just can't absorb the
flood of desperate hungry restless youth
seeking jobs that they don't find in
these urban centers
as a result
there are now 80 million young people
who are unemployed
another 150 million people on top of
that
are living very desperate marginal
livelihoods in the informal sector for
less than two dollars a day
youth now make up half of the unemployed
people on this planet
and as i already told you 85 percent of
these youth and all the problems that
come with them
are in the developing world the places
that need their talents and energy the
most
so
that's probably the first reason you
should care about the 85 frankly the 85
percent has the potential to be very
scary
first of all it's a it's a social
justice issue it's an economic issue and
it's an international security issue
because disenfranchised
youth living in poverty are prime
recruiting grounds for international
terrorists and local criminal
organizations
they cost their countries and local
economies millions if not billions in
lost potential and productivity
and in the informal sector where they're
trapped they're very vulnerable to
exploitation
the second reason you should care is
that they actually represent a really
big untapped opportunity it turns out if
that if we're able to cut the youth
unemployment in sub-saharan africa by
half
we would actually boost regional gdp by
12 to 19 percent that's huge
moreover folks like ck prahlad here
contend that there's a large untapped
market here at the bottom of the pyramid
a multi a multi-trillion dollar fortune
at the bottom of the pyramid that's up
for grabs for anyone who can see the
poor not as victims or beneficiaries but
as customers and collaborators
the last reason i have to care deeply
about the 85 percent is pretty personal
um as you know i've been working oops
sorry as you know i've been working at
the bottom of the pyramid with
my peers in the 85 percent
and i've got a big group of global kind
of youth volunteers that are focused on
eking out the opportunities that we know
exist in this population
now
we reject labels like lost generation
and ticking time bomb that are often
used to describe this 85 percent
instead we call ourselves generation
enterprise
we think that generation enterprise is
the only term that truly captures the
hope and resilience that these youth
bring in terms of their life experience
and their dreams
when it comes to building a better
future for themselves and their
communities
and i have to say i have learned at
least as much as i've taught my peers in
the 85 percent and i truly believe that
this spirit of friendship and
collaboration is actually a humbler more
inclusive frankly better way to do
economic development work in the 21st
century
also it's very tough not to feel deeply
connected to my peers when they send me
flip cam videos like the one i'm about
to show you
so
where were we so that's now that we've
established why we should care about the
85 percent
let's talk about generation enterprise
and what we're doing about it
so we've developed a model that focuses
on
uh tapping this potential in the 85 a
model that gets youth off the streets
and running businesses
this is how it works so it all starts
with empathy we partner with local
non-profits that refer youth to us and
we listen to their stories
we're screening them to be candidates in
our tightly knitted small cohorts of
generation enterprise fellows
now what we look for two things the
first is actions they've taken to
improve their lives this could be
something like escaping prostitution or
it could be as simple as seeking
vocational training
we also look for actions they've taken
to care for others so they often
manifest themselves in either family
situations or being the leaders of a
local gang
next what we do is we uh we focus on
these stories that allow them to tap
their deep personal experiences to truly
uncover customer needs in the
communities they hope to serve with
business solutions so the story i want
to share is one of bosch who's right
here so he came to us from freedom
foundation which was an ngo that
operates
safe houses for ex-gang members ex-drug
addicts and excess workers
and
he came to us at a point when he was
actually living in this one room shack
made of scraps of metal and wood and he
was working these odd jobs in local
churches to support his grandmother and
his three sisters because his parents
were gone
so
his dream was to build a real house for
his grandma and send his sisters to
school
and he was a perfect gen fellow because
folks like him folks like bash are
really eager to prove themselves and
work really hard and they also tap their
deep personal experiences to uncover
these community needs
uh bosch ended up you know anyone you
talk to here the design school at
stanford we'll talk about how deep
empathy
is at the heart
of design thinking
and bash was able to use these design
thinking tools to design his own
business which captures uh he is a
photography business that captures
family moments and community events
the second thing we do is take small
bets so after training our generation
enterprise fellows we then make small
bets on them and their ideas we give
them a mere ten dollars which they can
use to just test the most basic version
of their business ideas they pool their
funds and go through a series of
business experiments that help them
understand whether they're tapping a
true consumer need in a way that's
valuable enough for people to pay for
and the reason why that works is it's
about small bets and small bets are the
best way to fail fast get smarter for
cheap right and you know whether you're
talking about starbucks retail format or
google's pagerank algorithm
big breakthroughs come out of small bets
and anyone here in silicon valley will
tell you
that
you know
business plans don't survive their first
contact with reality what you need to do
is get out of the building and test it
and so that's what two of our business
two of our generation enterprise fellows
did this summer uh judith and olumide
ended up trying to tackle the problem of
nutrition in slums
so it turns out that whether you're
living in a gay gay lagos or the bronx
in new york city the poor you are the
poor you eat
and there's actually research that shows
that if you give a poor person a dollar
for food they're going to spend it on
sugar because something sugary because
almost biochemically their bodies crave
the comfort so judith and olumide had a
big problem cut out for them how do you
make healthy food attractive and
affordable to the poor in slums and so
they went through a series of different
experiments until they hit the jackpot
by learning that they could serve
individual packaged
individual serving sized fruit salads
refreshingly chilled and delivered to
you while you work
and the reason why they knew they'd hit
the jackpot and that it was time to make
a bigger bet was that they started
selling 30 packs a day
the last thing we do finally is launch
the full business so at this point we've
finished the test phase and we're
basically we've basically figured out
what most venture capitalists wish they
could do which is put their potential
investees under a microscope for four
months every day work alongside them and
understand how they're serving their
customers how they're managing their
money how they're refining their
businesses
so at this point we've already already
shaken out the best ideas and the most
viable
and hardworking youth and we then put in
a larger investment of up to a thousand
dollars so i know that's large is all
relative but here it's really large it's
a thousand dollars to more fully build
out the business and successful fellows
then reach out to us and are able to
channel their profits back to generation
enterprise as well as create at least
five other jobs for at-risk homeless and
unemployed youth in their communities
so what we're essentially doing here
is we're taking traditional venture
capital
into the slums
turning it on its head and giving it a
bit more heart
because traditional venture capital
basically involves looking for but
ultimately waiting for the best
entrepreneurs to match with the best
ideas and come to you so you can decide
whether to invest or not
what we do is we start with the right
youth the right entrepreneurs we
co-create the right businesses with them
and then we go big and we go into
business together and for us this is the
most sustainable solution to solving
this problem of youth unemployment
so now we come to the end what can you
do to help
now
the answer this is simple i want you to
join me in playing a game of who wants
to back a slum millionaire
so there's three steps to this it's very
simple to play the first one is share
what you know
now uh
we've already run three pilots in lagos
we've worked with 45 youth and launched
14
low-tech consumer brands in the slums
now what we're looking to do is scale we
know we've got something that works here
but there are a lot of questions scaling
is really tough i mean how do you mass
produce startups
how do you find the right business
models
you know how do you who do you work with
who can we partner with
these are all questions i need your help
answering and so i ask you today to
actually email me at
claragenerationenterprise.org
think about who we should talk to who in
your contacts what in your experience
can help us get to scale
the second is to make small bets again
it didn't take a million dollars or a
game show to take timmy or judith or
lumiere out of poverty and give them
choices and dignity
so i'm asking you for 10 bucks
this is all it takes to actually test in
business to make sure it's viable
and then if it is then we'll make we'll
figure out how to make the bigger
investment
the last thing to do is if you're really
brave launch an incubator generation
enterprise has been invited to 15
different countries from india to
colombia to cameroon we can't be in all
those places at once but we want to
reach these youth so if you're willing
join us as a team member come on as a
board member or launch your own
incubator and share what you're learning
when it comes to making slum
millionaires
so i want to finish by just going back
to that slum millionaire in the making
timmy remember him he's the guy from
timmy soap
and his business is growing rapidly he
could expand to cover all the different
zones in the city of lagos and all the
thousands of trash pickers who could use
his services he could become the bath
and body works of nigeria
no matter what happens though
he is making money that will keep him
off the streets allow him to start a
family hire others and frankly become a
respected and contributing member of his
community
and really that's where we want to get
to i think that's the goal
because even if timmy falls short of
becoming a slum millionaire
at the end of the day timmy his family
his employees and all of us
who care about this entrepreneurial
generation
we'll have one
thank you
you